i've just been talking to a lot of folks
recently especially like north korea
yeah
starvation and i remember
from my grandmother
it wasn't
any time and time again
not having food to eat is the thing that
people say is the worst
everything
it's way worse than murder
not having food and the places that
takes your mind and the actions that
forces you to do
that's terrifying and all of that seems
very distant in our history yeah i love
her i watched that interview with her
she is i want to talk to that woman so
bad because when she was on joe and she
sat there and said joe's like
do you have you done any therapy and she
laughed i was like oh that's my girl
it's such a fascinating i mean i would
love for you to kind of talk to her and
explore her mind because we kind of
explored her story right and that's
there's power and importance for a story
but it's so
difficult to understand
like how does she become
healthier and better
uh even more so than she's already she's
she's recovered
quite a bit you know she's found herself
quite a bit but i wonder
is she haunted
you're saying questions i want to ask
like that's what i mean because
after
being in a war
there are certain things there's certain
atrocities that you see that no matter
it doesn't matter the therapy
that you do and i don't care what all
the special ops guys say like i know
plenty of them that have a light switch
and they turn it off and they can
function but i also know them when
they've been out for 10 years
there's things that haunt people
differently
but there's no way there's not something
going on there deeply
yeah but it's also extra levels of
complexity in her case because um
i mean this is what just looking at
history about family
is she spent
much of her early life
loving
the dictator
right we like the water or something
like we like water or we like this
because there is no like individual like
when they said there was no love or
anything but there is a love for the
just that individual for that individual
and so i mean it's like the ultimate
abusive relationship oh yeah and uh but
but it's still love the experience like
you don't know the alternative so it's
not even
it's complicated because like
i i wonder if you truly explored it what
you would find because uh
the trauma much of her trauma i think
comes from when she was escaping north
korea
treatment by china
uh it's like the mom and she had to
witness within that and being helpless
with that yeah
so it's like evil men essentially
abusing her trading her you know and and
doing so nonchalantly like it's part of
just the way of of life
that i wonder if she sees kind of
yeah it's so complicated because
childhood it would be normal to her
because she didn't know any different
exactly and then there's
like uh i grew up poor but i i never
sensed that
because parents didn't make you well and
everyone else around was too right and
so you don't notice it i mean it's a
cultural thing so the way you grow up
you only start to notice it when you
compare yourself to others when you
learn of the alternative that's the dark
reality when you're abused
you um
i wonder i mean you truly and begin to
suffer in some kind of way when you
understand that you were being abused
that that's a dark kind of thought
that i wonder if you live your whole
life just in that abuse
if you don't know better that that's a
safer that's like uh what's a better
life
going suffering and then learning that
you're suffering or just suffering until
your last days there's a two ways to
look at this i'd argue on one side that
suffering
and suffering till you die
you know no different so you can't have
hope you can't have
this idea that there's better and
sometimes that's
keep that in its box but then if you
have kind of what you have with park
where she
she knows now that there's different she
knows that there's better then you run
into those what is the damage that has
been done what is going to be passed on
as intergenerational trauma i know she's
a mom so it's like now you got to look
long term a little bit because now she's
an influence on a child and
there's
there's a positive to looking at both i
would say and i know that sounds
horrible for the living and trauma your
whole life and just not knowing any
better
but there's
i don't know if that saves the brain
and the body and just just that overall
or if it actually
would be better because there's no way
to really find that out i don't think
yeah i think but the reality is when you
give people hope and you make them
realize that they're
suffering you're putting a burden on
them that's the first step on a long
journey and so and obviously she now
that she knows that the suffering she
wants to make uh people in north korea
currently
suffer less
and that's that admirable goal it's
it is it's what we do to each other is
try to like
when you see suffering in the world you
try to make it better and unmask that's
probably in a long arc of history going
to
make for uh
for a better world
you